over the last year I've had quite a lot
on my plate every single day right
somewhere between 6,000 to 10,000 words
for freelance writing clients on top of
that I have been working for hundred
authorial
that involves writing another three to
four thousand words much more heavily
researched often involves programming
sometimes also involve traveling
somewhere to cover a live event doing
some filming etc on top of that I've
been running the bio near that's the
website and the YouTube channel which
I've grown to over 100,000 subscribers
I've written a whole book and I've
gained a diploma on top of that I've
been experiencing being a father for the
first full year which really does take
up quite a lot of your time and somehow
on top of all this I've still managed to
socialize and watch all of Parks and
Recreation but I'd be lying if I said
that I wasn't sometimes a bit burned out
I've definitely struggled with being
overwhelmed and sometimes I'm so in my
own head I've got so many different
balls in the air that I forget crucial
things and very basic things start going
wrong I Drive people mad but I've been
using a bunch of different habits lately
to try and improve this and quite
frankly a lot of these I've been using
for a long time and who wasn't for them
but I wouldn't been able to do all that
at all in the first place so in this
video for other entrepreneurs and people
who work online or anyone who's facing a
little bit of overwhelm or would like to
achieve more in their day these are some
of my favorite productivity hacks so the
first one I want to talk about is
something called eating the whole frog
and apparently this comes from a quote
by Mark Twain that says if your job is
to eat a frog then you should do that
first thing in the morning if your job
is to eat two frogs you should eat the
biggest and ugliest one first I'd also
like to add to that that you should
probably change your job but basically
what he's saying here is that you need
to do the biggest most ugly tasks first
and that's something I subscribe to 100%
I think if I'm starting my day and I've
got to write a 10,000 word ebook on
something then I'm gonna sit down I'm
gonna do that before I do anything else
that means before I answer any emails
that means before I do any smaller tasks
or anything I want to do this is
important because it basically means
that I'm providing the most value as
quickly as possible
I'm doing the biggest task which is
probably gonna get me paid the most
probably gonna win over clients the most
and at the same time it means that's no
longer hanging over me and if I run out
of time at the end of the day it's much
easier to fit in
something small that you're looking
forward to doing than it is to fit in
something huge that you don't want to do
so instead of putting it off just get it
out the way and this also acts as great
training it builds great habits this is
actually why I get so annoyed at clients
who just want to talk and send emails
and discuss changing things every two
minutes because I'm just like if you're
paying me to do something if you want me
to do something then let me do it it's
this simple rule that's allowed me to be
as productive as I have been over the
last five to ten years of course sitting
down and doing the most horrible thing
that you don't want to do first isn't
always easy and that's why I really like
a tip from the book how to save an hour
every day by Michael Heppell he says
that you should use little rewards
throughout the day and set smaller
benchmarks and goals to get your work
done so for instance most of us will
start a working day at 9:00 we'll go and
make ourselves a coffee or browse
through emails maybe have a cheeky look
at Facebook and then sit down to do the
first thing we need to do that day it's
like half past 9:00 and you've achieved
nothing and that's quite a deflating way
to start your day
so instead sit down eat the whole frog
set out to write that 10,000 word ebook
or to do that huge data entry project
but then set yourself a target so that
when you've done X amount of work or
entered n number of data rows then you
can go and have your coffee and then
when you've done another chunk of work
that you set as a goal then you can go
and answer those emails
now it gets 9:30 and you've already
bitten off a huge chunk of the work
you've got to do and you feel far better
about yourself as a result not only that
B often find you end up pushing yourself
a little bit further once it gets to
thousand words it's going really well
you're like well I can do 2500 before I
have my coffee
you're also drink less coffee and if
you're anything like me that's a really
good thing because well I have a
caffeine addiction another way you can
encourage yourself to dive straight into
that big task that you really don't want
to do is to leave a project unfinished
the day before this is quite
counterintuitive because most of us
think that we should try and polish
everything off from close up for the day
but actually if you know that you've got
10,000 words to write on a book tomorrow
tonight before you go home try and write
500 words or 400 words what this does is
it opens it up
so it means that it's started firstly
that means you don't have that jarring
friction of starting a new project which
is the hardest bit to do especially
first thing in the morning when you're
tired at the same time the brain hates
things being unfinished and so the fact
that there's an open unfinished task
just sitting there on your desk top
means you're far more likely to open up
and get stuck straight in because you
want it done but if you get into work
and you need to start something fresh
and you didn't have any warning the day
before then you might find yourself
staring at a blank screen and it's not
just writers who struggle with writer's
block so another tip I can give you is
to just start writing start entering
data start coding don't worry about the
fact that your brain is kind of slowly
trying to churn into gear and you're
kind of lagging behind you're not sure
of what you're writing is great quality
maybe not even really engaged with it
just get writing because you'll get into
the flow then you can always go back and
check if what you're right was ok but in
order to get into that flow state in
order to get productive you need to just
push past that initial resistance and
again this is really good training it'll
become easier and easier if you just
dive into work as a result something
else that I do that's really useful to
me anyways is to think about how I'm
gonna spend my time in between work and
that means prepping for the next day and
I do this by doing research by thinking
about problems when I'm not actually
working it's really important that you
take down time that you rest properly so
I'm not saying that you should do this
all the time throughout your evening but
if you're stuck in traffic in the car if
you're waiting in the queue or if you're
just happy to think about works it's
actually something you enjoy which is
kind of important I'll get back to that
in a moment then why not think about the
project you're gonna do this is quite
cool because sometimes I'm just standing
there staring into space and then a
friend or a family member will say what
you're doing and I say programming which
is which is cool right because you can
think of solutions to programming
problems and you can think of article
structures we can think of your
arguments whilst you're not starting
from the computer and if you do that the
night before when you're relaxing or
doing something else then when you go to
work the next day you can just boom get
on with work and churn it out I really
love researching topics with a pioneer
in the evening I write bad things I'm
really interested in whether it's
productivity with its numerous science
whether it's training and so I'm more
than happy to just sit there and flip
through different articles on my iPad or
to listen to audiobooks or some cooking
etc and like many people on YouTube
lately I've been using something called
notion to keep all these ideas in one
place notion lets me stick any articles
that I find any useful notes or any
ideas all into one place I can open up
easily to refer to when I'm working
later on make a video and future on my
favorite apps and my favorite tools for
productivity if this is something you'd
like to see let me know in the comments
down below like I say should do this all
night with stuff that you really don't
want to do if you get home from work and
you spend your whole evening thinking
and worrying about project
to do the next day then you're not gonna
rest you're not gonna recover and you
won't perform optimally the next day so
you do need that downtime you need
proper rest that's kind of like the yin
to the yang of productivity but like I
say it doesn't matter so much if what
you're doing is something you actually
really want to do and if you can achieve
that if you can make sure that what
you're doing is something you really
want to do and this will make a huge
difference and be a massive boon and
hope to be far more productive the most
important key ingredient to do your best
work and to be happy churning out huge
amounts of volume is to be passionate
and to be inspired by it
inspiration is different from motivation
motivation is pushing yourself to do
something when you don't want to
inspiration is having exciting ideas
about the thing dreaming about how it's
gonna look when it's finished and being
excited to get started on it so how do
you become inspired about work that you
don't really want to do first of all if
you find that you keep having to do work
that you don't find inspiring at all
then I suggest you have a real think
about the work you're doing consider
changing jobs obviously this isn't
always an option
and even if you love your job you don't
love every single part of what you're
doing so another thing to do is to try
and look at whatever it is you're doing
and make it more interesting so if
there's a particular task you have to do
find a way to either gamer fire or just
to do your very best job look at great
inspirational examples of the work
you're doing think about the craft that
goes into it
think about the artistry that maybe
you're not thinking about properly and
then find a way to turn this into
something that you can feel pride in and
that you can get excited to do but like
I say in an ideal world to choose a job
where you are inspired by what you do
and you'll be more than happy to put in
extra time and you will find that to be
relaxing because it's what you'd be
doing in your downtime anyway then there
are all those little smaller niggling
tasks that get in the way and a lot of
people say Tim Ferriss for instance says
that you should close open loops and
open loops being anything like an email
that you don't respond to booking your
tax calling a client all these small
tasks that don't take much time that
they take a lot of mental effort to
think about so how do you marry this
idea closing those open loops as soon as
possible with just doing that big chunk
of work right away do you do the big
chunk of work or do you close the apron
loops how can you do both the answer I
think is that those open loops should
never even make it on to do list in the
first place because you should tackle
them immediately this is what some
people refer to as the 1-minute rule if
you take plates out into the kitchen
don't stick them on aside
stick them in the washing machine I mean
dishwasher I always say that always call
the dishwasher the washing machine if
it's an email from a client you
to answer just answer it right away in
other words don't let these things play
on your mindset you have a huge task
list of things to do it's gonna drag you
down and make you feel miserable instead
just tick them off right away so you
don't even need to think about them when
you start work and you start that big
project if they're longer than one
minute do them at the end of the day or
create a snippet of time create chunk of
time to tackle them in the exception to
this one minute rule of course is whilst
you're focused on that big chunk of work
leave the book deep work by Cal Newport
it's really good he talks about the
importance of being completely focused
on your work and not being interrupted
by whatsapp or slack so in other words
turn off those notifications so you're
not being constantly pestered by them so
that you can just focus on the work you
need to do that way it's not a question
of do you do the big task or the small
task because those smaller interruptions
don't arise in the first place
ideally you want to be in a state of
almost sensory deprivation when you're
working on these big tasks some of these
smaller tasks will be recurring things
that come up again and again like
putting on that dishwasher and I'm not
just talking about productivity in the
office or at work but also at home
because these things do overlap so when
it comes to doing the dishwasher or
answering emails these are kind of
recurring tasks that you know you're
gonna have to do most days so I
recommend finding a way to schedule them
into your routine so you can put them
into the most efficient block of time
but you're already doing something else
I always do the dishwasher in the
morning for instance whilst I'm also
making my daughter's breakfast this is
just a good spot of time to do it and I
give her some toys to keep her busy in
the high chair zombie tasks are
particularly good for this zombie tests
at any test but don't require your
conscious mind something you could do
whilst watching television so for
instance I can be making a thumbnail
because design I can do whilst doing
something else so I always like to make
my thumbnail whilst watching TV in the
evenings because that way I can be
present and chat to my wife I can watch
TV and at the same time I can create
thumbnails I know I'm gonna have to do
if you think a week that's a recurring
task and if there are tasks that you
need to do regularly and you just can't
bring yourself to do them like tidying
your office you can try one more tip
from the book atomic habits this is
called temptation bundling and basically
it means you take something you don't
want to do like ties in your office
organizing or deleting old emails and
then you bundle that with something you
do like to do for instance drinking an
iced coffee
so this is another time where you can
use a reward like that to make something
more bearable or maybe you listen to a
podcast or maybe you listen to something
else that's interesting maybe this is a
really nice coffee like a delicious
latte or cappuccino and the reason
that's important is because you're only
gonna do this thing when you do that bad
task so the only way to get the nice
thing is through the task you don't want
to do
suddenly you're more like
to do that task I do recommend that you
keep all these smaller to do written
down so that you don't forget them and I
really like the app todoist there's many
more like it I'm really interested in
getting an Apple watch because I love
the idea of having to do it on my wrist
but for now it's great on my phone and I
can just tick things off as I go through
the day and I can even just ask Alexa to
add things to my to-do list when I think
of something new so I hope found this
video useful interesting guys if you did
then please leave a like down below
comment and subscribe that stuff all
helps me out immensely I did mention a
while back that I was thinking of
working on a new channel called the bio
matrix I was going to talk specifically
about productivity and working online
and I was gonna do that separately from
the Byun ear that would focus more on
Fitness bias on Instagram without
something you wanted me to do and he
also did rather it was all in one place
because that's partly what makes this
channel unique it's not just fitness its
self-improvement in general including a
lot of fitness a lot of training and a
lot of neuroscience and that kind of
stuff so yeah I'm gonna be keeping these
kinds of videos on the channel I'm gonna
be doubling down on them so let me know
what you think and if there's any topics
you'd like me to cover in future
share your favorite productivity hacks
down below or if you've got any books
and things I love getting your tips
really appreciate that thanks a ton for
watching and I'll see you next time bye
for now